we were promised an autobiography that
was raw and unflinching it has
absolutely delivered my understanding
that the the mood at the palace is one
of shock one of disbelief and Prince
William was said to be devastated and
seething over this autobiography Prince
Harry's highly anticipated tell all
Memoir spare is officially here and the
Duke of Sussex is dropping some major
Bombshells among them Harry claims he
learned his brother Prince William got
engaged to Kate Middleton through the
Press I think Harry's ultimate goal in
releasing this Memoir is to tell his
truth and he wants to take control of a
narrative that he feels hasn't been his
for far too long in the book Harry says
he learned his brother pop the question
at the same time everyone else did
admitting when the palace announced
William and Kate's engagement it was
news to him and while Harry officially
served as William's best man on his
wedding day Harry says his brother's
real best men were his two friends James
and Thomas Harry claims William didn't
want him to give a best man speech
either quote he didn't think it's safe
to hand me a live mic and put me in a
position to go off script I might say
something wildly inappropriate he wasn't
wrong
of course this isn't the only tense
moment with William Harry recalls in
spare Harry's detailing of the of the
physical fight between him and William
was was shocking to read and we we know
that the brothers
um had fallen out that they were not on
talking terms but to discover that
actually things had gotten so bad that
they became physical it is quite
shocking yeah Harry claims William
physically attacked him after the two
got into an argument over Harry's wife
Meghan Markle back in 2019. Harry talks
about a Red Mist coming over his brother
and in that moment this is the anger
bubbling up in William there is this
moment where clearly these brothers are
just not on the same page they are poles
apart they simply cannot understand one
another and while promoting the release
of his Memoir Harry explained why he
didn't fight back if I wasn't
doing therapy sessions like I was and
being able to process that anger and
frustration that I would have fought
back 100
um but I didn't because I was in a more
comfortable place with my own anger but
he was very he was he wanted me to to
head him back but I chose not to but
despite everything that's gone down
Harry told 60 minutes he still has hope
they can reconcile
I look forward to having a relationship
with my brother I look forward to having
a relationship with my father and other
members of my family he speaks about
wanting to reconcile with his family he
talks about the door being open but I
think the feeling is that actually he's
made sure that door has been firmly
slammed shut the idea of any
reconciliation seems almost Unthinkable
given what he has said given the very
personal nature of these attacks because
that's what they are they are verbal
attacks on members of the royal family
and not just any member of the royal
family his father his brother his
mother-in-law his sister-in-law no one
is really spared in spare
foreign